good morning John I'm gonna be
completely honest sometimes I feel like
a huge gigantic failure and we all feel
like that and we're all petrified of
failure but John one thing that gets me
through all of my failures and keeps me
trying new projects day in and day out
despite the fact that I probably will
fail is knowing that there are other
people who have made decisions that led
to much bigger much much more
significant failures than I will ever
even have the opportunity to even get
close to matching the level of those
failures today so that you and the rest
of the world can know that your failures
no matter how big they seem to you are
actually insignificant I'm going to give
you a list of the top seven most epic
fails of history that aren't in any
specific order and that are actually
just the ones that I think are the most
interesting start out in 1962 when a
young four-man band walked into Decca
Studios for an audition the Decca
studios manager concluded that the band
had quote no future in show business a
mere two years later that band which we
all know as the Beatles sold fifty
million dollars of records gigantic epic
fail number two went a little bit like
this men congratulations we have been
fighting a war with the Greeks for many
many years they have all left and behind
all that there is is this beautiful
horse that they have made us to
congratulate us for our victory over
them let us bring it into the walls of
our city and leave it unguarded
overnight epic fail number three getting
involved in a land war in Asia it's one
of the classic blunders more
specifically if you're trying to take
over all of Europe just don't just leave
Moscow out of it just let them be
similarly if you are as small though
very technology sophisticated and
interesting island nation don't send a
bunch of bombers over to bomb country
that you're not currently at war with
especially if that country has just
developed the bomb that can destroy
entire cities sometimes it seems like
these epic fails aren't being made by
one person but they are them their
decisions being made by men but on a
more understandable scale we have the
1960 performance of wim
the first Olympian from the nation of
Suriname and his performance which will
go down in history as the first Olympian
from Suriname was to sleep through his
race moving further back in time in 1876
western union owned the entire system of
communication in America in 1876
gardener green hovered a perched western
union with a patent for a device called
the telephone the CEO of Western Union
went ahead and bypassed the agent of
sale wrote a letter directly to
Alexander Graham Bell saying that
Western Union had no need of this
electrical toy Alexander Graham Bell
instead of closing up shop created his
own telecommunications network which he
named American Telephone & Telegraph the
telephone became the most valuable
patent in history so tell me in the
comments despite the fact that none of
your failures have ever led to the
deaths of millions of people or to the
loss of billions of dollars why are we
so afraid of failure and in lieu of that
what is it do you think that you're
afraid of John I'll see you on Monday